.
HOW DO WE MAKE THE IDEA AND
AUTHOR TAUGHT OR READING SOUND
LESS BORING AND THE ISSUE IS SO
FEW OF US HAVE THE TIME IN THE
DAY TO PIECE THIS TOGETHER
SUCCINCTLY AND BRILLIANTLY AND
WATCHING RYAN TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING AS BORING AS
GOVERNMENT POLICY BUT HOW IT
REPRESENTED SOMETHING ON A MAP,
A SHIFT HOW DRUGS MOVE FROM THIS
COUNTRY AND WITH THE RELATED TO
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE NEED AND
WHAT WE HUGHES, WE DESIRE AND
HOW WE TRY TO GET IT IS A TRULY
BRILLIANT THING.
IT DOES CHANGE THE WAY YOU VIEW
THE COUNTRY AND THE GEOGRAPHY
AND HOW WE DEAL WITH PEOPLE.
SO THIS IS AN HONOR TO MIND.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT BOOK AND
NECESSARY.
"THIS IS YOUR COUNTRY ON DRUGS"
IS SOMETHING EVERYBODY CAN READ
SO THERE'S NOT A REASON TO TRY
NOT TO READ IT AND WITHOUT
FURTHER ADO, JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING RYAN GRIM.
[APPLAUSE]
-- BEFORE, THANKS, ALEX, THAT
WAS KIND.
AND THANK YOU TO EVER BELIEVE IT
CAME TO LIGHT.
I APPRECIATE THIS.
THIS BOOK GETS COMPLEX AT TIMES
THE START OF A VERY SIMPLY ABOUT
EIGHT YEARS AGO I REALIZED I
HADN'T SEEN LSD AND PROBABLY
THREE YEARS.
I STARTED LOOKING FOR IT.
I STARTED ASKING FRIENDS WHO GO
TO FISH SHOWS OR BURNING MAN OR
RAINBOW GATHERING, PLACES WHERE
YOU REALLY WOULD EXPECT TO FIND
LSD JUST AS MUCH AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO FIND YOUR WALKING INTO
A BAR AND THEY KEPT REPORTING
BACK TO ME KNOW, I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT.
AND THE YEARS WENT ON AND IT
BECAME SOMETHING THAT WAS
ENTIRELY UNEXPECTED.
HOW CAN THIS DRUG THAT HAD BEEN
SUCH A PROMINENT PART OF OUR
CULTURE BE ON AVAILABLE TO
22-YEARS-OLD HIPPIES ALL OF A
SUDDEN?
AND SO THAT'S WHAT IN THE UP
LAUNCHING THIS BOOK AND IT ALSO
-- I WILL START RIGHT HERE WITH
THE DISAPPEARANCE OF LSD.
SO I WENT TO SEE A PROFESSOR IN
MY DEPARTMENT, PETER REUTER, ONE
OF THE MOST WELL-RESPECTED DRUG
RESEARCHERS IN THE NATION.
ACID IS GONE, I TOLD HIM.
HOW DID YOU COME TO THIS THEORY,
HE ASKED.
I CAN'T FIND IT, I SAID, AND
NONE OF MY FRIENDS CAN EITHER.
I KNEW I SOUNDED LIKE A FOOL BUT
THAT'S ALL I HAVE.
THAT'S NOT HOW WE DO THINGS IN
THIS FIELD, HE SAID.
DRUG AVAILABILITY GOES IN
CYCLES.
IT'S NOT A TREND, THAT IS HOW IT
IS.
HE POINTED TO A BOOK BEHIND ME.
HAND ME THAT.
HE OPENED THE 2002 MONITORING
THE FUTURE REPORT PUBLISHED BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN AND
TRACKS DRUGS USED BY TEAMS.
AS YOU WILL SEE COMEGYS SAID,
RUNNING HIS FINGERS ACROSS THE
LSD TABLE, USE HAS BEEN OVER THE
LAST -- HE PAUSED AND LOOKED UP
AND SAID, LOOKING AT THE DATA
FOR HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS, LSD USE
IS AT A HISTORIC LOW, 3.5%.
HE THEN CONTINUED WITH HIS
LECTOR TELLING ME ABOUT SUPPLY
AND DEMAND IN PEAKS AND VALUES
AND HE WAS CERTAIN THE MEMBER
FOR ACID WOULD RISE IN 2003
SURVEY.
DRUGS CYCLES ARE WIDELY PRESUMED
TO BE THE RESULT OF A
COMBINATION OF CULTURAL SHIFTS
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF DRUG
INTERDICTION BUT THEY ARE
GENERALLY NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD.
SUPPLY AND DEMAND, HOWEVER, AND
ARGUABLY PLAY A LARGER ROLE.
WHEN THE DRUG BECOMES SCARCE IT
IS INCREASED ENTICING PRODUCERS
AND DISTRIBUTORS TO INVEST MORE
HEAVILY WHICH INCREASES SUPPLY,
WRITER EXPLAINED.
I TOLD HIM I WASN'T SO SURE.
THEY'RE SIMPLY WAS NO ACID OUT
THERE AND HADN'T BEEN FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
I RAMBLED ON ABOUT THE END OF
THE GRATEFUL DEAD AND COLLAPSE
OF GIANT RAVES.
HE WASN'T MOVED.
CHECK THE 2003 NUMBERS, HE SAID.
THEY MAY BE ON LINE BUY NOW.
IF LEVELS REMAIN THE SAME THEN
YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING.
THE TO SELL SOME THREE NUMBERS
-- I CHECKED THE YEARS, IT WAS
1.9%.
NEARLY 50% DROP.
I CHECKED A FEW OTHER SOURCES.
EVIDENCE ABOUT SAID EQUINE COULD
BE FOUND PRACTICALLY EVERYWHERE.
IN THE FOLLOWING STATISTICS AN
ONGOING FEDERAL SURVEY DRUG USE,
IN A NUMBER OF EMERGENCY ROOM
CASES INVOLVING THE DRUG, IN A
HUGE DROPOFF A FEDERAL ARREST
FOR LSD I TOOK THE NUMBERS BACK
TO REUTER.
THIS ISN'T A TREND, HE SAID.
THIS IS AN EVENT.
LIKE ALL DRUGS, ACID IS A
BELLWETHER OF AMERICAN SOCIETY.
ITS EFFECT ON OUR CULTURES IN
THE 60'S AND 70'S WAS A
MEASURABLE AND ITS DISAPPEARANCE
IN THE EARLY YEARS OF THE 21ST
CENTURY WAS LIMITED TO THE
UNITED STATES.
CULTURAL COMMENTATORS TO LOOK
FOR TRENDS AND UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS, PRESIDENTIAL APPROVAL
RATINGS OR HOUSING AND CAR
PURCHASES ARE MISSING SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTAL IF THEY DON'T
CONSIDER STATISTICS ON DRUG USE.
LITTLE TELLS MORE ABOUT THE
STATE OF AMERICA THAN WHAT
AMERICANS ARE DOING TO GET HIGH.
LIFE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
COURSE A SIMILAR IN MANY WAYS TO
LIVE ANYWHERE IN THE DEVELOPED
WORLD.
BUT OUR NATION DIVERGES SHARPLY
FROM THE REST OF THE WORLD IN A
FEW CRUCIAL WAYS.
AMERICANS WORK HARD.
135 HOURS A YEAR MORE THAN THE
AVERAGE BRITON, 240 HOURS MORE
THAN THE TYPICAL FRENCH WORKER
AND 370 HOURS, NINE WEEKS, MORE
THAN THE AVERAGE GERMAN.
WE ALSO PLAY HARD.
A GLOBAL SURVEY RELEASED IN 2008
FOUND AMERICANS ARE MORE THAN
TWICE AS LIKELY TO SMOKE POT AS
EUROPEANS.
42% OF AMERICANS HAVE PUFFED AT
ONE POINT, CITIZENS FROM VARIOUS
NATIONS WERE ALL UNDER 20.
WE ARE ALSO FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY
AS SPANIARDS TO HAVE DONE COKE
AND ROUGHLY TEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY THAN THE REST OF EUROPE.
QUOTE, WE ARE JUST A DIFFERENT
KIND OF COUNTRY, SAID THE U.S.
DRUGS ARE SPOKESMAN TOM RILEY
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE SURVEY.
QUOTE, WE HAVE HOW YOUR DRUG USE
RATES, HIGHER CRIME, MANY THINGS
THAT WITH A FREE AND MOBILE
SOCIETY.
DIFFERENT, INDEED.
THERE MAY BE NO PEOPLE ON EARTH
WITH A MORE TWISTED COMPLEX
RELATIONSHIP TO DRUGS.
MUCH OF OUR PRECONCEIVED
SELF-IMAGE TURNS OUT TO BE
WRONG.
LIBERTINE CONTINENTAL'S HAVE
NOTHING OF US IN TERMS OF DRUG
USE AND AMERICAN PIETY HAS
PRESENTED US FROM INDULGING IN
FACT SOMETIMES ENCOURAGED IT.
MUCH OF OUR CONVENTIONAL WISDOM
ABOUT AMERICAN DRUG USE THAT THE
PURITANS AND MEMBERS OF OUR
FOUNDING GENERATION WERE
TEETOTALERS OR MILD DRINKERS,
THE DRUG TRADE IS DOMINATED BY
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
THE MAFIA AND THE BLOODS, THAT
CRACK USE DECLINED SIGNIFICANTLY
SINCE THE 80'S TURNS OUT TO BE
WRONG, TOO.
IF THERE IS ONE CERTAINTY ABOUT
AMERICAN DRUG USE, IT IS THIS,
WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR A
BETTER WAY TO FEED OUR APPETITE
FOR GETTING HIGH.
FOR SOMETHING CHEAPER, FASTER,
LESS ADDICTIVE OR MORE POWERFUL.
DRUG CAN FEED THEMSELVES AS WORD
SPREAD ABOUT THE AMAZING NEW
HIGH THAT IS SAFE AND NOT
ADDICTIVE THING WE DISCOVERED
OTHERWISE AND GO SEARCHING FOR
THE NEXT GREAT HIGH.
WE CIRCLED BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
DRUG FOR GETTING WHY WE QUIT IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
SO WHAT HAPPENED TO ACID?
THAT WAS -- I ORIGINALLY WROTE
ABOUT THIS IN 2004, AND I HAD A
FEW THEORIES, BUT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BOOK WAS TO ACTUALLY GO OUT
AND FIND OUT WHAT -- WHAT
HAPPENED TO LSD.
I CAME UP WITH FOUR THEORIES,
AND ONE OF THE POINT OF THIS
BOOK IS THAT THERE IS NO ONE
FACTOR THAT LEADS TO A DRUG
TREND EITHER GOING ON OR GOING
DOWN.
IT'S ALWAYS A COINCIDENCE OF A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT FACTORS
HAPPENING UNIQUELY IN THAT TIME
PERIOD.
SO THE FIRST THING AND MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN THIS CASE WAS
AN ARREST.
THERE WAS A KANSAS, THERE WAS A
KANSAS MISSILE SILO THAT WAS
ACTING AS THE CENTRAL PRODUCTION
FACILITY FOR ALMOST ALL OF THE
LSD ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT WAS TAKEN DOWN IN NOVEMBER
OF 2000.
AND THE SUPPLY WAS IN THE
PIPELINE, SO THAT EXPLAINS WHY
BY THE END OF 2000 OR SO YOU
STOP SEEING -- AND OF 2001 TO
STOP SEEING IT.
NUMBER TWO, THE DELIVERY SYSTEM
WAS DISRUPTED.
IN THE MID-90S, GRATEFUL DEAD
STOP TOURING.
IN 2000, FISH TOOK A BREAK.
I FOUND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FIELD REPORT THAT SHOWED
THAT WHEN THE GRATEFUL DEAD
WOULD COME THROUGH A CITY,
AVAILABILITY OF PSYCHEDELIC
DRUGS IN THAT AREA WOULD
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE MONTHS.
EVERYBODY -- THINK OF IT AS LIKE
A PSYCHEDELIC POSTAL SERVICE
THAT ADVERTISING WHEN IT'S
COMING TO TOWN.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE THIRD
THING, WHICH IS THE COLLAPSE OF
TRY AND RAISE.
AS PEOPLE WHO WERE OVER 30 HERE,
I SEE A COUPLE OF YOU, MIGHT
REMEMBER IN THE NINETIES THERE
WAS THIS EXPLOSION OF FIELD
PARTIES, WHERE HOUSE PARTIES,
WHERE YOU WOULD HAVE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF KIDS, AS YOUNG
AS 14 SOMETIMES UP INTO THEIR
TWENTIES, WHO WOULD MEET IN
THESE LONG SANCTIONED PARTIES
AND THE ACID AND OTHER
PSYCHEDELIC DRUGS WERE
EVERYWHERE SO THE KIDS WOULD GO
TO THE PARKING LOT OF THE
GRATEFUL DEAD OR FISH SHOW EVEN
IF THEY DIDN'T GO TO THE SHOW
THEY WOULD GET A COUPLE SHEETS
OF ACID, TAKE IT TO THE ARRAY OF
AND ACID IS NOT THE KIND OF DRUG
THAT YOU NEED TO BUY EVERY
WEEKEND OR EVERY DAY OR 40 TIMES
A DAY LIKE MOST OTHER DRUGS.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO DOWN TO
THE STREET CORNER AND SAY HEY,
BUDDY, YOU HOLDING ANY ACID?
YOU'RE GOING TO GO WHERE YOU
KNOW IT IS AND PEOPLE KNEW WHERE
IT WAS.
SOME PEOPLE HAD THOSE THREE
THINGS.
NOW, WHY DIDN'T SOMEBODY STEPPED
INTO THE BREACH?
PART OF IT, AND THIS BRINGS US
TO THE FOURTH THING, PART OF IT
IS THAT THE PRODUCTION OF LSD IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT, AND IT'S
ALSO NOT VERY PROFITABLE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE AN ILLEGAL
DRUG DEALER AND YOU ARE IN IT
FOR THE MONEY, YOU'RE GOING TO
DO SOMETHING THAT HAS THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF RISK AND MOST AMOUNT
OF PROFIT.
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS ARE STRICTER,
LSD WILL LAND YOU IN PRISON
POSSIBLY THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
THE GUY DUSTIN KANSAS CURRENTLY
SERVING TWO CONSECUTIVE LIFE
SENTENCES.
AND HE IS INTO,, SO THE SECOND
-- I'VE BEEN CORRESPONDING WITH
HIM FOR FIVE YEARS -- THE SECOND
LIFE SENTENCE REALLY BOTHERS
HIM.
IT REALLY DOES.
[LAUGHTER]
THE FIRST ONE BOTHERS HIM A LOT,
TOO, OF COURSE.
BUT SO, YOU HAD TO BE IN THE
BUSINESS ALMOST AS A CHARITABLE
GESTURE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
MAKING A LOT OF MONEY BECAUSE IT
IS NOT A COMMODITY THAT MOVES
WHILE.
IT WAS -- IT'S FIVE BUCKS FOR A
HIT AND THE KIND OF THING AFTER
YOU DO IT, YOU KNOW, MOST PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO TOUCH IT AGAIN FOR
MONTHS ON END AND MAYBE THE REST
OF THEIR LIFE.
THEY SAY THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
ME.
I'VE BEEN OUT THERE.
I DON'T NEED TO SEE THAT AGAIN.
THINK ABOUT IT COMPARED TO SAY
COCAINE OR ECSTASY, DRUGS EITHER
EASIER TO GET OR WITH ECSTASY
EASIER TO MAKE.
YOU CAN GET $25 FOR UPHILL OF
ECSTASY, AND WHEN THE PERSON IS
FINISHED THAT THEY ARE VERY
LIKELY TO BE LIKE HEY, YOU KNOW
WHAT, I MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
THEY CAN BLOW THROUGH HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS IN A WEEKEND WHERE AS
THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT THE CASE
WITH LSD SO THERE IS LITTLE
INCENTIVE TO GET INTO IT BUT IT
ALSO BECAME MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THIS STRANGE GEOPOLITICAL REASON
TO GET THE PRECURSOR.
THROUGHOUT THE 80'S AND 90'S
ACCORDING TO PSYCHODELIC
COMMUNITY PEOPLE I SPOKE ONE OF
THE KEY PIPELINES FOR THE
PRECURSOR FOR LSD OR DINING
TITRATE, WAS COMING FROM THE
EASTERN EUROPEAN SOVIET BLOC,
AND IN THE LATE 80'S -- SO THEY
SHOT THIS DOWN.
SO THE LATE 80'S WHEN THE SOVIET
UNION COLLAPSES IT COMES BACK
TOGETHER AND IT STARTS FLOODING
-- STARTS FLOWING OUT OF EASTERN
EUROPE BECAUSE IT IS A
COMPLETELY UNREGULATED
CAPITALISTIC SOCIETY AND THE
GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT GOING IN AND
CHECKING WHAT KIND OF CHEMICALS
THESE FACTORIES ARE MAKING AND
CERTAINLY THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY ARE MAKING SOME PRECURSOR
OF THE UNITED STATES DOESN'T
WANT SHIPPED IN.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT WAS ONLY UNTIL THE U.N. CAME
TOGETHER WITH THIS GLOBAL TREATY
AND 99 THE DAY FINALLY STARTED
SHIPPING THE WAS DOWN.
AND THERE ARE SOME PRESS REPORTS
THAT PEOPLE SENT ME THAT SHOW ME
THAT THIS R COLTON TERRORIST
GROUP IN JAPAN THAT LET OFF SOME
STINK BOMB IN THE SUBWAY ALSO
WAS INVOLVED IN LSD AND WAS
PROVED THAT LSD HAD RUSSIAN
ORIGINS.
SO THE SUPPLY WAS CUT OFF IN THE
LATE NINETIES.
SO YOU HAVE A COLLECTION OF
FACTORS WORKING TOGETHER, AND IT
ALMOST VANISHES.
SO I WANTED TO LOOK AT WELL, IS
THAT THE FIRST TIME THAT'S
HAPPENED IN AMERICAN SOCIETY,
AND ALSO IN AMERICAN HISTORY?
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO THE PEOPLE
WHO USE TWO OR STILL HAVE AN
APPETITE, STILL HAVE A DEMAND
FOR THE DRUG WHAT ARE THEY DOING
INSTEAD?
SO, I ALSO WANTED TO MAKE THIS A
GOOD LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
DRUG BOOK.
MOST DRUG BOOKS START IN ABOUT
1965 AND THEY'VE RUN THROUGH
AMERICAN HISTORY SORT OF LIKE IT
IS A VH1 ROCKUMENTARY.
THERE'S THE RISE IN THE 60'S,
EVERYTHING IS GREAT, THE PARTY
IS RAGING IN THE 70'S.
IN THE 80'S THINGS GET A LITTLE
OUT OF CONTROL, THEN THEY GO TO
AA AND THEN THERE'S WISDOM,
MATURITY, RECOVERY AND THE BOOK
WILL HAVE AN INTERVIEW WITH
JERRY GARCIA OR HUNTER THOMPSON
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND
THAT'S THE PICTURE THAT YOU GET
OF AMERICAN DRUG USE.
I WANTED TO STRETCH IT FURTHER
BACK AND FIGURE OUT WHAT REAL
PEOPLE WERE DOING.
NOT THAT JERRY GARCIA IS NOT A
REAL GUY THAT PEOPLE OTHER THAN
HIM HAVE BEEN DOING.
SO, ONE OF THE MOST SURPRISING
THINGS TO ME IS WHAT I FOUND
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE TEMPERANCE MOVEMENT IN THE
19TH CENTURY AND THE RISE OF
OPIUM SMOKING AND OTHER FORMS OF
OPIUM THROUGHOUT THE 1830'S SO
WE MOVE TO THAT.
AT THE TIME, AND WE ARE TALKING
1830'S, AT THE TIME THERE WAS
LITTLE RESEARCH ON EXPLORING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OPIUM USE
AND DRINKING BUT THERE WAS AT
LEAST ONE NOTEWORTHY STUDY
COMING IN 1870 TO LOOK AT THE
OPIUM BY THE MASSACHUSETTS STATE
BOARD OF HEALTH.
THE REASON FOR THE DRAMATIC
UPSWING HAD CONCLUDED WASN'T THE
CHINESE OR THE CIVIL WAR, IT WAS
THE TEMPERANCE MOVEMENT.
THIS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
THE CALL FOR SOBRIETY WASN'T
UNIQUE TO THE UNITED STATES, THE
BOARD FOUND.
QUOTE, IT IS A SIGNIFICANT FACT
BOTH IN ENGLAND AND THIS COUNTRY
THE TOTAL ABSTINENCE MOVEMENT
WAS ALMOST IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED
BY AN INCREASED CONSUMPTION OF
OPIUM.
THE STUDY SUGGESTED EASY
ACCESSIBILITY TO THE JOB
THROUGHOUT PHARMACIES WAS PART
OF THE REASON FOR THE INCREASE
BUT MANY OTHER SOURCES EXISTED
AS WELL.
ONE OFFICIAL REFERRED TO AS A
STATE SAY YOUR REPORTED TO THE
BOARD OPIUM HAS BEEN RECENTLY
MADE FROM WHITE POPPY CULTIVATED
FOR THE PURPOSE IN VERMONT, NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND CONNECTICUT.
THE ANNUAL PRODUCTION BEEN
ESTIMATED BY HUNDREDS OF POUNDS
AND THIS HAS GENERALLY BEEN
ABSORBED IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE IT IS MADE.
IT HAS ALSO BEEN BROUGHT HERE
FROM FLORIDA AND LOUISIANA WHILE
COMPARATIVELY LARGE QUANTITIES
ARE REGULARLY SENT EAST FROM
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA WHERE ITS
CULTIVATION IS BECOMING AN
IMPORTANT BRANCH OF INDUSTRY.
10 ACRES OF POPPIES BEING SET TO
YIELD AN ARIZONA, 1200 POUNDS OF
OPIUM.
ALTHOUGH THIS DESCRIPTION OF A
THRIVING DOMESTIC OPIUM PROBLEM
MIGHT NOT SOUND SURPRISING
TODAY, THE BOARD'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE CROPS
CONSUMERS CERTAINLY DOESN'T.
QUOTE FROM THE OPIUM HABIT IS
ESPECIALLY COMMON AMONG THEM IN
EFFECT REPASSES IT ASSERTS, OR
TO ACT TO LIVE REGARDLESS OF ALL
HYGIENIC LAWS.
IT PUTS SOME OF THE BLAME FOR
SUCH LOWER CLASS USE ON DOCTORS
AS WE STILL DO TODAY, WHO ARE,
QUOTE, IN NO SMALL MEASURE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MORAL AS
WELL AS PHYSICAL WELFARE OF
THEIR PATIENCE AND SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED TO GET AWAY WITH THE,
QUOTE, IN JUDICIOUS AND OFTEN
UNNECESSARY PRESCRIPTION OF
OPIUM.
AMERICA'S BETTER HAVE MADE UP,
QUOTE, SO LARGE A PROPORTION OF
OPIUM TAKERS THE STUDY SUGGESTS
BECAUSE WOMEN WERE, QUOTE,
DOOMED OFTEN TO A LIFE OF
DISAPPOINTMENT OF THE PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL INACTION AND THE
SMALLER AND MORE REMOTE TOWNS
NOT ON FREQUENTLY TO UNDER
SECLUSION.
THE, QUOTE, MOST IMPORTANT CAUSE
OF OPIUM TAKING WAS THE SIMPLE
DESIRE FOR STIMULATION.
AND URGED OTHER TO SATISFY BY
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION.
OPIUM, THE REPORT NOTED, WAS
BOTH MORE AVAILABLE AND MORE
SOCIALLY ACCEPTABLE THAN
ALCOHOL.
THE NARCOTIC, QUOTE COME CAN BE
PROCURED AND TAKEN WITHOUT
ENDANGERING REPUTATION FOR
SOBRIETY.
ONE TOWN MENTIONED IT WAS
THOUGHT MORE GENTEEL THAN
ALCOHOL.
THE REPORT WENT ON TO SAY THAT
IT WAS, QUOTE, BETWEEN THE WING
ON TO SAY IT WAS BETWEEN 1840
AND 1850 SOON AFTER TEETOTALISM
HAD BECOME A FIXED FACT HOUR OWN
IMPORTATION OF OPIUM SWELLED,
CITING A RISE OF 350%.
IN ENGLAND, ONE DOCTOR NOTED
OPIUM SHOOTING HAS BECOME
PREVALENT ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
USE OF ALCOHOLIC DRINKS HAS BEEN
TO SUCH GREAT EXTENT ABANDONED
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF THE
FASHION INTRODUCED BY A TOTAL
ABSTINENCE SOCIETIES.
THE BOARD ALSO FOUND, QUOTE,
CURIOUS AND INTERESTING AS WINE
DRINKING ADVANCED IN TURKEY,
OPIUM RETREATED.
AS ALWAYS IN AMERICA, THE LIMIT
OF WHAT EXACTLY IS MORAL
BEHAVIOR DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
MEANING IS.
BY FOLLOWING THEIR VERSION OF
GOD'S CODE TO THE LETTER
TEETOTALING AMERICANS OF THE
19TH CENTURY FREELY VIOLATED ITS
SPIRIT.
AND WE SEE THIS THAN PRETTY MUCH
ALL THROUGHOUT AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE MASSACHUSETTS BOARD OF
HEALTH PUT IT PERFECTLY THE
DESIRE FOR STIMULATION.
THAT'S WHAT WAS DRIVING PEOPLE
TO USE OPIUM.
ONE DRUG BECOMES A STIGMATIZED,
OR LESS AVAILABLE, BUT THE
DESIRE TO GET HIGH OR TO GET ANY
BRIGADE ON SOME TYPE OF
SOMETHING DOESN'T GO AWAY.
SO, AMERICANS GO SEARCHING FOR
SOMETHING ELSE IF THEY CAN'T
FIND EITHER WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE
OR WHAT IS AVAILABLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LATE 70'S,
THE EXACT THING HAPPENS AGAIN
WITH THE DECLINE OF MARIJUANA
AND LIES OF COCAINE.
WE ARE MAKING NO EXCUSES FOR
DRUGS.
HARD, SOFT OR OTHERWISE,
PRONOUNCED RONALD REAGAN ON
JUNE 24, 1982.
A VETERAN OF MANY PITCHED PACING
CONTESTS WITH THE COUNTERCULTURE
WHILE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE LATE 60'S HE WAS EAGER TO
TAKE IT ON AGAIN WHEN HE BECAME
PRESIDENT.
AFTER THEM AS I'VE SAID BEFORE,
WE ARE TAKING ON THE SURRENDER
FLAGS AND RUNNING UP THE BATTLE
FLAG.
WE'RE GOING TO WIN THE WAR ON
DRUGS.
REGAN REDOUBLED EFFORTS AND
CURBING IMPORTS FOR THE IMMELT
JUL STRAUB POLICY AND BROUGHT
ABOUT MANDATORY MINIMUM
SENTENCES FOR MINOR DRUG
OFFENSES.
IN 1980 THE FBI UNIFORM CRIME
REPORT LISTED TO WITHIN 100,000
ARRESTS FOR HEROIN AND COCAINE
TABULATED TOGETHER.
BY 1989 THE FIGURE JUMPED TO
MORE THAN 700,000.
BUT THE FIRST BATTLE CREEK AND
WOULD FIGHT IN THE WAR WAS
AGAINST MARIJUANA, WHICH
REQUIRED LEADING SIEGE TO THE
ONCE IGNORED BASIC LIBERAL
RESISTANCE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HIS CAMPAIGN AGAINST MARIJUANA
PRODUCTION, CAMP, BEGAN IN THE
HARVEST SEASON OF 1983.
U-2 SPY PLANES AND MILITARY
COPTERS FLIGHT OVER THE GOLDEN
STATE LOOKING FOR GRAIN CROPS.
BUT THE FALL, CORN AND WHEAT AND
SOYBEANS TURNED BROWN MAKING
CANNABIS EASY TO SPOT FROM THE
SKY.
THE D.A. REPORTED SEIZING 64,000
PLANTS WITH AN ESTIMATED VALUE
OF $130 MILLION.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR TO
THE STREETS CHANTING WAR ON
DRUGS, WAR ON DRUGS.
THE OPPOSITION PRINTED BUMPER
STICKERS DEMANDING U.S. OUT OF
HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
THE 1984 CULT WAS THREE TIMES
LARGER.
NATIONALLY, POT PLANTS SEIZURES
ROSE FROM 2.5 MILLION IN 1982 TO
MORE THAN 7 MILLION IN 1987 AND
ANNOUNCED THAT RIVALS THE
GOVERNMENT'S PREVIOUS ESTIMATE
OF THE ENTIRE DOMESTIC CROP.
REAGAN EVEN BEGAN TO GO AFTER,
QUOTE COLLEGE WE'D COME A WILD
VARIETY OF HEMP THAT HAS NO
POTENTIAL TO GET A USER HIGH.
THE FIRST YEAR THE WHITE HOUSE
KEPT THE EFFORT TO DITCH THE
ERADICATION IT CLAIMED TO
APPROVE ABOUT 9 MILLION PLANTS.
THAT NUMBER WAS UP TO MORE THAN
120 MILLION BY 1989 AND REACHED
I SERIOUS ABOUT THIS, HALF A
BILLION IN 2001.
UNSURPRISINGLY, SUCH SUSTAINED
EFFORT DROVE UP THE PRICE OF
MARIJUANA.
THE D.A. CLOSELY TRACKS DRUG
PRICES AND THE PURITY OF THE
ALTHOUGH IT DOESN'T MAKE THE
DATA AVAILABLE PUBLICLY IT DID
MOST RECENTLY IN 2004 AND THE
NUMBERS INCLUDE A STARTLING IF
MISUNDERSTOOD OBSERVATION.
QUOTE, THE MARIJUANA PRICE
TRENDS ARE NOT HIGHLY CORRELATED
WITH TRENDS IN PRICES OF OTHER
DRUGS OVER TIME, THE REPORT
READS.
ONE OF THE PRICE OF POWER,
HERRON AND TO A LESSER EXTENT
CRACK OR FALLING DURING THE
1980'S, THE AVERAGE PRICE OF
MARIJUANA GENERALLY ROSE.
AND EIGHTH OF AN OUNCE OF POT IN
1981 AND IN $2,002 WAS GOING FOR
$25.
EST. ROUGHLY THE SAME IN 1982.
BY 86 IT WAS AT $53, AND IT HIT
A HIGH OF $62.91.
A 50% RISE OVER TEN YEARS.
COKE MEANWHILE BECAME MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE.
THE COST NEARLY $600 A GRAM IN
'82.
AS RECONSTRUCTED RESOURCES
TOWARD THE POT BATTLE COKE'S
PRICE BEGAN TO TUMBLE.
BY 80 NEGATIVE WAS DOWN TO $200
A GRAM CHEAPER IN REAL TERMS
THAN IT HAD BEEN DURING THE LAST
COKE A BINGE EARLIER.
AT THE SAME TIME AVERAGE PAY
LEVELS NEARLY DOUBLED.
CLEARLY THE PRICE TRENDS ARE
HIGHLY CORRELATED THE
CORRELATION IS IN NEGATIVE ONE.
IN THE 80'S PRICE INCREASES IN
THEIR ON DROVE THE DEMAND TO
OTHER DRUGS.
THE WAR ON DRUGS HARD, SOFT OR
OTHERWISE, HELPED PERSUADE PAUL
SMOKERS TO PUT DOWN THE BALL IN
AND PICK UP THE NEEDLE.
I BEGAN SEEKING ANY JOB TREND IS
THE RESULT OF A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT COLIN FACTORS.
SO, RIGGINS'S WAR OF MARIJUANA
CAN'T BE SAID TO BE THE SOLE
CAUSE FOR THE WIVES OF COCAINE
POPS RESPONSE FOR BRINGING
COCAINE INTO AMERICA IN THE
80'S, AND I SAID NOT QUITE, BUT
CERTAINLY HE WAS INVESTING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF RESOURCES
GOING AFTER MARIJUANA WHICH
DROVE, AND THAT DOES HELP TO
DRIVE PEOPLE TOWARDS THE TROPICS
WHERE THE PRICES ARE GOING DOWN.
THE EXPLICIT POLICY OF THE DEA
IS TO INFLUENCE THE PRICE OF
DRUGS.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO GET RID
OF DRUGS TO THEIR STATED GOAL IS
TO INCREASE THE PRICE OF DRUGS
WHICH THEY SAY WILL THEN REDUCE
DEMAND.
SO BY THEIR OWN THEORY THE
IMPACT OF THEIR POLICY IN THE
LATE 70'S AND MOST ESPECIALLY IN
THE EARLY 80'S COMING AFTER
MARIJUANA DROVE PEOPLE TOWARDS
COCAINE.
COCAINE ALSO FIT WITH THE 80'S
TIMES AND THAT'S ANOTHER THEME
OF THE BUT THEN YOU CAN TELL OF
ABOUT AMERICA BY WHAT PEOPLE ARE
GIVING TO GET HIGH AND YOU HAVE
THESE CULTURAL MOMENTS AND MOODS
THAT MESH AND A DRUG COMES IN
AND IT'S THE APPROPRIATE ONE FOR
THE TIME.
SO THE 80'S WERE A GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THAT SO LET ME READ A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT.
AND PART OF THE REASON IS I
ARGUE IN THE PITCH BEFORE THIS
THE COLLAPSE OF THE
MANUFACTURING ECONOMY.
THE COLLAPSE OF AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING LEFT MORE THAN A
PSYCHIC NEED, HOWEVER.
IT ALSO LEFT A VACUUM IN THE
ECONOMY WHICH THE NON-GOOD
PRODUCING SERVICE INDUSTRY
RUSHED TO FILL.
ACCORDING TO A 1992 "NEW YORK
TIMES" STORY, QUOTE, THERE WERE
MORE JOBS CREATED IN NEW YORK
CITY THAN THE 1980'S
OVERWHELMINGLY HIGH SKILLED
HIGH-PAYING THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
BUFFALO, THE STATE'S LARGEST
CITY.
WE BECAME A NATION OF MIDDLE
MANAGERS OF BANKERS AND
BUREAUCRATS, OF ADJUSTORS,
COUNTERS AND WAITPERSONS AND
DRUG DEALERS.
FROM THE IMPORTER TO THE
DISTRIBUTOR TO THE GUY ON THE
CORNER.
PETER REUTER WHO HELPED ME WITH
MY ARTICLE HAS MADE A CAREER OUT
OF EXAMINING ECONOMICS OF THE
LOCAL BUSINESSES.
ONE OF HIS MOST STARTLING
OBSERVATIONS IS THE COKE TRADE
INDEED IN THE ENTIRE DRUG TRADE
IS ESSENTIALLY A SERVICE
INDUSTRY BECAUSE THE STREET
PRICE OF A DOSE OF COCAINE IS
MANY TIMES HIGHER THAN THE COST
OF NEARLY MANUFACTURING.
AS WITH ANY DETAIL GOOD SOME OF
THE EXCESS COVERS THE SELLER'S
PROFIT.
SOME COVERS WHAT ACCOUNTANTS
CALL TRANSPORTATION COSTS WHICH
MUCH MORE GOES TO THE DISKING
PRODUCT SEIZURE AND EMPLOYEE
UNREST THE PRINCIPAL PERILS OF
PROVIDING AN ILLEGAL SERVICE.
THOSE PANELS BECOME LESS
SIGNIFICANT THE MORE THE SOUTH
FLORIDA COAST INDUSTRY BECAME
ENTRENCHED AS COCAINE'S PRICE
FELL THROUGH THE DECADE IT
BECAME AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS OF
MORE MODERATE MEANS.
IT TRICKLED DOWN SO TO SPEAK
SPREADING ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
BOTH POWDER AND CRACK FORM.
DURING ITS HIGH-PRICED HAITI,
HOWEVER, COKE WAS KNOWN AS A
PROFESSIONAL DRUG.
EMPLOYEES OF THE LEGAL SERVICE
INDUSTRY BENEFITED FROM THIS
PRODUCT OF THE ILLEGAL SERVICE
INDUSTRY AS THEY WORKED LONG
HOURS IN THEIR SECTOR OF THE
ECONOMY.
IT'S EXCLUSIVITY BUT WITH
AWKWARDLY MOBILE AND THE
SEVERELY IMPOVERISHED DREAMED OF
BEING PART OF.
ON AND PLOWMAN HAD CLAIMED IN
THE LATE 70'S AS PLANTS SHUT
DOWN AND AMERICAN CITIES
CRUMBLED.
STAGFLATION AND WAGES AND JOB
GROWTH WERE FALLING OIL PRICES
WERE RISING.
A PHENOMENON SOME ECONOMISTS HAD
THOUGHT IMPOSSIBLE.
BY THE CLOSE OF THE DECADE
INFLATION WAS APPROACHING 15%
AND INTEREST RATES HAD RISEN
ABOVE 20%.
TO LASSO THE PEACE REAGAN
TIGHTENED MONETARY POLICY
CUTTING THE MONEY SUPPLY
INTENTIONALLY DRIVING THE
COUNTRY INTO RECESSION.
THE REAGAN RECESSION AS IT
BECAME KNOWN HIT HARD IN THE
SUMMER OF 1981 AND PERSISTED THE
NEXT YEAR AND A HALF.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING
BOTTOMED OUT AND IN THE 1982
MIDTERM ELECTIONS DEMOCRATS
PICKED UP MORE THAN TWO DOZEN
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
AMERICA WAS NO LONGER A PLACE
WHERE THINGS WERE MADE.
IT WAS A PLACE WHERE THINGS WERE
SHUFFLED OR NOT.
COCAINE SLOTTED NICELY INTO THE
NEW ECONOMY.
THE REAGAN RECESSION AFFECTED
URBAN BLACKS AND LATINOS AND
AMERICAN CITIES A LIVING.
THE ECONOMY NEEDED TO PICK ME UP
SELLING COKE PROVIDED.
THE BANKING INDUSTRY HAD ENDING
UP BY THE RECESSION AND WAS GLAD
TO HAVE THE INFLUX OF CAPITAL
BROUGHT BY THE COCAINE BUSINESS.
THE ECONOMISTS REPORTED 44 MIAMI
BANKS WERE GIVEN INTERNATIONAL
CHARTERS IN 1982 COMPARED TO THE
TANNIN 1978.
ANOTHER 36 FOREIGN BANKS OPENED
BRANCHES IN MIAMI DURING THE
PERIOD.
AT LEAST 40 BANKS REFUSE TO
REPORT CASH DEPOSITS OF MORE
THAN $10,000 AS REQUIRED BY LAW
THROUGHOUT THE 70'S AND IN THE
80'S.
AND I LEAST FOUR BANKS
AUTHORITIES ESTIMATED WERE
BOUGHT AND CONTROLLED BY DRUG
DEALERS.
AS THE TRADE SPREAD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, DEALERS FOUND STILL
OTHER BANKS EAGER TO DEAL IN
COCAINE CASH.
MUCH OF THE MONEY THAT WENT TO
FARM PRODUCERS ENDED UP IN THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY THROUGH THE
PANAMANIAN BRANCHES OF U.S.
BANKS.
BY THE LATE 80'S A FEW BANKS HAD
BEGUN TO COME UNDER SUSPICION AS
MONEY LAUNDERING BECAME TOO
BLATANT.
BUT THE PENALTIES WERE LAUGHABLY
SMALL EVEN WHEN THE BANKS DID
GET CAUGHT THE OFTEN STILL
BENEFIT FROM THE TRANSACTION.
IN BEVERLY HILLS BRANCH OF THE
AMERICAN EXPRESS BANK WAS CAUGHT
LAUNDERING $150 MILLION
BELONGING TO AN OPERATOR OF AN
UPROARIOUS CARTEL WITH CLOSE
CONNECTIONS TO THE THAN MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
IN A 1994 CONGRESSIONAL HEARING,
CHAIRMAN HENRY GONZALEZ, TEXAS
DEMOCRAT, NOTED THAT THE
950,000-DOLLAR FINE, LESS THAN
1% OF THE LAUNDERED CASH MEANT
THE BANK STILL PROFITED FROM THE
EXCHANGE.
CITIBANK, WHICH SINCE THE 1950'S
HAD BEEN THE MOST ACTIVE U.S.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION IN MEXICO
WAS A PERFECT POSITION WHEN
COCAINE TRAFFICKING MOVED FROM
THE CARIBBEAN WEST.
MEXICAN PLAYBOY RAUL WAS
DISCOVERED TO HAVE LAUNDERED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS TO PURSUE
THE BANK.
HIS BROTHER, PRESIDENT CARLOS, A
PROMINENT ALLY IN THE U.S. DRUG
WAR WAS ESTIMATED TO MAKE SOME
7 BILLION HIMSELF.
AND TO HANDLE HALF YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION BEGINNING IN 1986
SENATOR JOHN KERRY'S COMMITTEE
LOOKING AT LINKS BETWEEN THE CIA
AND CONTRAS TURNED UP TIES
BETWEEN DRUG CARTELS AND BANKING
INDUSTRY.
ONE HEARING AND WALT THE
CARTEL'S TOP ACCOUNTANT, RAMON,
WHO HAD BEEN BUSTED LAUNDERING
BILLIONS THROUGH THE NEW YORK
BASED BANK OF BOSTON.
A COMMITTEE MEMBER SUGGESTED HE,
QUOTE, MUST BE VERY CLEVER TO
HAVE CLEANED UP SO MUCH, TO HAVE
CLEANED UP SO MUCH CASH.
BILL, FIRST BOSTON PAID THE FINE
OF $25,000, DURING 42 YEARS, HE
RESPONDED, WHO DO YOU THINK IS
CLEVER?
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW OUR TIME IS
BUT IF ANYBODY HAS QUESTIONS, I
FOUND AT THESE READINGS THERE
OFTEN ARE A LOT OF THEM.
>> YOU TALKED EARLIER ABOUT A
PRECURSOR FROM RUSSIA AND I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU MEANT
BY PRECURSOR.
>> LSD BASICALLY COMES FROM
MORNING GLORY SEEDS, BUT THE
MORNING GLORY SEEDS ARE TURNED
INTO A PRECURSOR OF THE CALL
E.T..
WITHOUT THIS IS EFFECTIVELY
IMPOSSIBLE -- RIGHT, TO MAKE
LSD, AND I DON'T KNOW OF ANYBODY
THAT CAN ON AN INDUSTRIAL LEVEL
THAT CAN BE REMOTELY PROFITABLE
IN THE MORNING GLORY SEEDS.
IF YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT IN A
TRAILER OR WHATEVER LIKE MISSILE
SILO THAT HE MIGHT BE OPERATING
OUT OF, YOU NEED THIS TITRATE
WHICH MAKES LSD A VULNERABLE
CHILD BECAUSE IF YOU CAN FIND
THE TITRATE PRODUCERS AND SHUT
THEM DOWN THEN YOU CAN DO WHAT
IS VERY HARD TO DO IN THE DRUG
WORLD WHICH IS TO USE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO REDUCE
SUPPLY.
BECAUSE IT IS SO HARD TO MAKE IT
AND UNDERGROUND IT MAKES THAT
MUCH MORE VULNERABLE.
IT IS SIMILAR TO CUI LEADS.
THESE REQUIRE A CERTAIN
PRECURSOR THAT A BUNCH OF GERMAN
COMPANIES WERE MAKING AND IT
TOOK THE U.S. LIKE TEN YEARS TO
PERSUADE THEM TO SHUT DOWN AND
WHEN THEY SHUT DOWN THAT WAS IT.
THEY ARE NOT THAT MUCH FUN OR
ELSE SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE FIGURED
OUT HOW TO DO IT.
THEY MUST NOT BE THAT RADICALLY
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OTHER KIND
OF DONNER YOU CAN GET.
RIGHT.
I DON'T WANT TO SPOIL THE BOOK,
BUT THE CHINESE HAVE GOTTEN INTO
THE PSYCHEDELIC BUSINESS IN
RECENT YEARS AND NOT ONLY CAN
YOU FIND THE TITRATE OR LSD.
YOU CAN FIND ALL OF THESE DRUGS
WHICH ROSE AFTER LSD DISAPPEARED
THEY ARE CALLED RESEARCH
CHEMICALS.
THE EXISTED BEFORE LSD BUT THE
INTERNET AND DISAPPEARANCE OF
ACID INCREASED THE USE OF THESE
THINGS CALLED RESEARCH
CHEMICALS.
THE REASON THEY ARE CALLED
RESEARCH CHEMICALS IS THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO OUTLAW A CHEMICAL
SUBSTANCE.
SO WHAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO DO
IS SAY THIS KUNKEL SUBSTANCE --
CHEMICAL SUBSTANCES ILLEGAL IF
IT IS USED FOR RECREATIONAL
PURPOSES, IF IT IS USED FOR A
GOOD TIME.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU ARE
MAKING A DRUG THAT IS FOR A MOOD
DISORDER OR FOR THE FLU OR
WHATEVER ELSE AND YOU CAN DO
RESEARCH BUT IF THE PURPOSE IS
FOR A GOOD TIME THAN IT IS
ILLEGAL BECAUSE LSD, AND YOU CAN
TWEAK THE MOLECULAR STRUCTURE OF
IT AND MAKE A PSYCHEDELIC DRUG
THAT DOES SOMETHING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
IT MIGHT LAST A LITTLE LONGER,
IT MIGHT BE LESS OR MORE
POWERFUL, IT MIGHT GIVE YOU A
DIFFERENT KIND OF TRIP.
NOW THERE IS A GUY OUT IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAS BEEN DOING
THIS FOR DECADES, ALEXANDER
SHELEPIN, AND HE -- IF YOU LOOK
AT THE SCHEDULED ONE LIST OF
DRUGS WHICH IS THE MOST ILLEGAL
DRUGS IT IS LIKE THE WHO'S WHO
OF DRUGS THAT HE'S CREATED.
WHAT HE DOES IS HE WORKS WITH
THE MOLECULES OF SOME
PSYCHEDELIC AND THEN HE FIGURES
OUT A WAY TO MAKE IT SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
AND HE PUBLISHES HIS RESULTS
ONLINE AND THEN HE NEVER DOES IT
AGAIN.
THE D.A. THEN SEES HE'S
PUBLISHED AND MAKE THAT ONE
ILLEGAL.
THE WAY THAT HE GETS AWAY WITH
IT IS HE SAYS I AM MAKING A
CHEMICAL SUBSTANCE THAT HAS
NEVER EXISTED BEFORE IN THE
WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IS GOING TO BE
PSYCHEDELIC.
IT MIGHT BE.
IT MIGHT NOT BE.
AND SO HE SAYS OF HIMSELF AND IT
TURNS OUT IT IS A PSYCHEDELIC.
SOMETIMES IT IS TOTAL GARBAGE.
HE WRITES ABOUT IT AND THAT'S A.
HE STILL HAS NOT BEEN POSTED.
AND HE WON'T BE BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE A TOUGH CASE TO MAKE.
>> HAVE YOU SEEN ANY STUDIES
INCURRING THE TRUCKS TODAY WITH
THAT OF TEN, 20, 30 YEARS AGO?
>> YEAH, HE ASKED ABOUT THE DRUG
USE TODAY COMPARED TO TEN, 20,
30 YEARS AGO AND THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF GOOD SURVEYS.
THERE'S ONE THAT'S CONDUCTED BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN THAT
GOES BACK TO 75 THAT IT STARTED
OUT TRACKING HIGH SCHOOLERS, AND
IT'S FOLLOWED A LOT OF THE HIGH
SCHOOLERS AND NOW IT ATTRACTS
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES AND ANOTHER
ONE IS THE NATIONAL SURVEY ON
DRUG USE AND HEALTH WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL SURVEY.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT ONE IS
THEY CHANGED THE NAME.
IT USED TO BE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SURVEY ON DRUG ABUSE AND
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE NAME OF
THAT.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS PERSUADING
PEOPLE TO GIVE NEGATIVE ANSWERS.
IN A SURVEY PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
PERSUADED TO GIVE BECAUSE IT IS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COMING TO
THE DOOR AND ASKING IF YOU DO
WITH ILLEGAL DRUGS.
SO YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO ADJUST FOR
THE FACTOR IN THESE SURVEYS.
BUT MIGHT WORKING THEORY IN THE
BOOK WAS THAT YOU DO HAVE TO
ADJUST FOR THE FACTOR SO YOU
CAN'T REALLY TAKE THESE SURVEYS
AS GOOD ABSOLUTE NUMBERS BY YOU
CAN TAKE THEM AS FAR AS TRENDS
ARE CONCERNED AND UNLESS SOMEONE
CAN ARGUE -- AND IT'S POSSIBLE
TO MAKE THE ARGUMENT SOMEONE WAS
LYING MORE, PEOPLE WERE LYING
MORE IN 1978 AND TODAY.
THAT MIGHT BE POSSIBLE BUT IN
GENERAL, PEOPLE HAVE PROBABLY
LIED ABOUT THE SAME THE LAST 30
YEARS OR SO.
SO THE NUMBERS WERE MUCH HIGHER
IN THE MID 70'S.
YOU SEE A DECLINE STARTING
AROUND 79 DRUG USE COMES DOWN
THROUGH THE 80'S WHEN WE ARE
WAGING -- IT'S ONE OF THE MANY
IRONIES OF AMERICAN DRUG HISTORY
WHEN WE ARE FIERCELY WAGING THE
DRUG WAR AT A TIME DRUGS WERE
RECEDING SO YOU SEE THE NUMBERS
COMING DOWN THROUGH THE 80'S AND
THEN AND 91 YOU SEE WHAT SOME
PEOPLE CALL A RELAPSE UNTIL
ABOUT IN 2000 AND THEN BACK DOWN
AGAIN.
BUT NEVER IN THE MID NINETIES
DID REACH THE MID-70S.
THAT IS STILL THE PEAK OF DRUG
USE IF YOU DON'T COUNT ALCOHOL.
>> GIVEN THE CURRENT ECONOMY AND
THE TIES YOU SAID BETWEEN DRUG
USE AND THE ECONOMY AND CULTURE
WHAT IS YOUR HA TO PICK FOR 2010
FROGS?
[LAUGHTER]
MY DAY JOB IS A REPORTER FOR THE
HUFFINGTONPOST.COM AND THE STORY
THAT I WAS WORKING ON TODAY IS
ABOUT THE 2010 INITIATIVE THAT
MAY OR MAY NOT HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA TO TAX, REGULATE,
LEGALIZE MARIJUANA OUT THERE.
I AM HEARING THE PEOPLE BEHIND
IT ARE GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH
IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF DEBATE IN THE
MARIJUANA WORLD IF THEY SHOULD
DO THAT OR NOT AND THERE ARE BIG
ORGANIZATIONS FUNDED BY BIG
DONORS SAY IN 2010 IS IN THE
RIGHT TIME.
MIGHT BE A REACTIONARY PERIOD IF
THE ECONOMY STILL STINKS AND IT
MIGHT BE LIKE A 94 TIME, YOU
DON'T WANT A LIBERAL POSITION ON
THE BALLOT, BUT THE PEOPLE
PUSHING IT ARE SAYING IT'S
DIFFERENT WITH MARIJUANA THIS
TIME AROUND BECAUSE IF THE
ECONOMY STILL STINKS AND IF
CALIFORNIA IS ON THE VERGE OF
COLLAPSE OR BIDEN HAS COLLAPSED
THEN IT'S GOING TO BE AWFULLY
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO SAY NO I
WOULD RATHER NOT HAVE THIS
$2 BILLION IN TAX REVENUE OVER
SOMETHING THAT IS ALREADY
EFFECTIVELY LEGAL.
YOU CAN GET RECOMMENDATION FOR
MEDICAL MARIJUANA IN CALIFORNIA
-- I HEARD ABOUT THIS IN THE
BOOK THERE WAS ONE THAT SAID IN
L.A. WEEKLY THAT SAID ANXIETY,
INSOMNIA LISTED THREE OR FOUR
OTHER THINGS, ETC..
[LAUGHTER]
SO $100 YOU HAVE A MEDICAL
MARIJUANA CARD.
SO THIS WOULD TIGHTLY REGULATE
AND SAY DISPENSE WITH THIS
MEDICAL MARIJUANA REQUIREMENT
AND THE ESTIMATE IS BETWEEN 1.2
OR $2 BILLION ANNUALLY WHICH
THERE IS A COMMERCIAL RUNNING
NOW THE SYSTEM WOULD BE 20,000
TEACHERS SALARIES IN A YEAR.
SO IT IS A PERSUASIVE ARGUMENT
WHETHER OR NOT IT PREVAILS
REMAINS TO BE SEEN BUT MORE
BROADLY WHAT I LEARNED BY
STUDYING THE HISTORY OF DRUG USE
AND POLICY IS THAT IT WILL COME
FROM THE STATES IF MARIJUANA
DOES BECOME LEGALIZED THAT IS
THE WAY IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO COME FROM
CONGRESS.
SAN FRANCISCO WAS THE FIRST
PLACE TO EVER PROHIBIT A DRUG
AND WAS 1878 THE PAST AND OPIUM
WALL WHERE THEY SAID YOU CAN'T
RUN AN OPIUM DEN IF YOU ARE
CHINESE.
THEY WERE VERY EXPLICIT ABOUT.
TODAY WE ARE MUCH MORE
SOPHISTICATED AND OUR LAW MAKING
BUT BACK THEN THEY JUST WROTE
RIGHT IN THERE.
SO OTHER STATES SAW OTHER STATES
AND CITIES SAW THAT AND PASSED
IT AND 50 YEARS LATER USE GOT
MARIJUANA BECOMES ILLEGAL.
BUT FIRST HAD BECOME ILLEGAL IN
MOST STATES AND MOST TOWNS AND
COUNTIES.
AND IT WILL GO THE SAME WAY IN
REVERSE I THINK.
THE WAY THAT MEDICAL MARIJUANA
START IN SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
EARLY 90'S WITH AN INITIATIVE
THERE AND IT WENT FROM THERE TO
THE STATE LEVEL AND THEN WENT TO
OTHER STATES.
EVENTUALLY YOU WILL HAVE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHO REPRESENT A
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS WHERE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA IS ILLEGAL.
THAT'S VERY SOON.
IF ILLINOIS AND NEW YORK GO
WHICH COULD HAPPEN VERY SOON
THEN YOU WILL HAVE MAJORITY OF
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
REPRESENTING MEDICAL PAUL
STATES.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR VOTING
MEDICAL MARIJUANA COMES UP EVERY
YEAR.
AT PRESENT IT IS MORE LIKELY TO
VOTE FOR MEDICAL MARIJUANA IF
HIS STATE HAS ALREADY APPROVED
IT RATHER THAN HIS PARTY
IDENTIFICATION.
SO IT REALLY DOES COME FROM THE
BOTTOM OF PRESSURE.
>> I AM CURIOUS IF YOU SEE ANY
CORRELATION BETWEEN DRUG USE,
THE TYPES OF DRUGS TO STAND THE
POINT IN TIME WHEN THE FCC
ALLOWED TRUCK COMMERCIALS ON
TELEVISION.
AND HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE WHOLE
DRUG COMMERCIALS ON TELEVISION
AND HOW WE ARE BEING PROCEEDED
WITH THIS WHOLE "DO THIS DOGGETT
WILL MAKE YOU FEEL BETTER."
WELL, PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG USE
DID GO UP, PHARMACEUTICAL DRUG
ABUSE HAS BEEN GOING UP SINCE
THE EARLY PART OF THE DECADE.
I HAVE READ SOME PRETTY
CONVINCING STUDIES THAT HAVE
ARGUED THAT'S NOT THE REASON WHY
IT WENT UP AND THE RISE IN
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE ISN'T AS
LARGE AS IT IS MADE OUT TO BE IN
THE PRESS, BUT LIKE I SAID
THROUGHOUT MY BOOK ALL THESE
DIFFERENT DRUG TO TRENDS ARE THE
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT FACTORS AND
I THINK THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE,
AND A LOT OF THE TIME YOU DON'T
KNOW UNTIL A DECADE LATER UNTIL
YOU CAN LOOK BACK AND SEE
EVERYTHING THAT WAS GOING ON AT
THE TIME AND ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
DECENT NUMBERS TO GO BY.
THE MOST RECENT NUMBERS LIKE
COULD GET FROM THIS BOOK WENT
BACK TO 2006 FOR THE ONE FEDERAL
STUDY IN 2007 FOR THE OTHER ONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO SLOW AND
ANALYZING AND BRINGING THE DATA.
THEY ARE YEARS BEHIND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT GOES ON.
NOW, THE OTHER TELEVISION AD
ALSO WRITE ABOUT AND IT IS THE
ONE PARODY ON THE COVER HERE I
THINK IT ALSO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
DRUG USE, BUT LIFTING IT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THIS IS FRAMED BY --
ACTUALLY BEFORE I PUT THIS ON
THE COVER I ASKED A 22-YEAR-OLD
CO-WORKER, JUST SHOWED IT TO HIM
AND ASKED HIM YOU KNOW, WHAT IS
THIS AND HE SAID IT'S THE DRUG
AD.
I SAID HOW DID YOU KNOW THAT?
YOU WERE BORN AND LIKE 1987 OR
SOMETHING.
HE SAID I DON'T KNOW.
DUSTIN PART OF OUR CULTURE.
I KNOW THAT AD.
SO I WENT BACK AND WATCHED WHILE
WRITING THIS BOOK.
IT'S ONLY A 102ND AD WHICH I
HADN'T REMEMBERED.
SHOWS THE FRYING PAN, SHOWS THE
FLEEING EGG AND SAYS THIS IS
YOUR BRAIN ON DRUGS AND IT ENDS
WITH THIS CONTEMPTUOUS
RHETORICAL QUESTION THAT SAYS
ANY QUESTIONS.
AND THEY MEAN IT RHETORICALLY
LIKE OF COURSE YOU DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS.
WE JUST EXPLAINED EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
THIS IS GOING TO FRY YOUR BRAIN.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
-- YOUR FAMILY AND --
>> GOES THROUGH THE WHOLE
QUESTION TO THE KITCHEN IN
QUESTION AND BRICKS OF PLATES.
>> I LIKE THE NEW ONE WHERE IT'S
LIKE DRUGS WON'T DO ANYTHING,
YOU GO DOWN TO THE BASEMENT AND
THE BROTHER IS STILL LIVING
THERE WITH HIS FAMILY.
>> THEY HAVE GONE A COMPLETE NEW
180.
THIS IS JUST A YEAR AFTER THEY
WERE SAYING MARIJUANA WOULD MAKE
YOU RUN OVER A CHILD ON A
A YEAR LATER THEY ARE SINKING IT
WILL ONLY MAKE YOU GO DOWN ON A
COUCH AND YOU WILL BE A LOSER.
BUT THE BROAD POINT WAS ANY
QUESTIONS.
YES ACTUALLY I DO HAVE
WHAT IS THAT, WHY DOES IT TRY MY
BRAIN?
HOW DOES THIS WORK?
ARE SOME DIFFERENT THAN OTHERS?
AND SO PEOPLE WENT SEARCHING FOR
ANSWERS ELSEWHERE, DR. JURY AND
PEOPLE LIKE THAT WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANSWERS.
TWO THINGS.
ONE WHEN YOU ASK A QUESTION IF
HE CAN WAIT FOR THEM TO GET OVER
TO WITH A MICROPHONE THAT WE IT
PICKS THINGS UP AND ALSO JUMPING
OFF OF TOM'S POINT ABOUT LAST
WEEK ON CNN YOU MENTIONED
SOMETHING ABOUT THROUGH THE EASE
OF ACCESS BEING PART OF THE
SHIFT IN DRUG USE, YOU KNOW,
KIDS TOM CAHAL VERSUS OUT IN THE
FIELD, WE'D VERSUS
PHARMACEUTICALS AND I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN DISCUSS THAT A LITTLE
BIT AS WELL.
>> IT IS A REALLY OBVIOUS POINT
BUT ONE THAT STRUCK ME
THROUGHOUT AMERICAN HISTORY THAT
PEOPLE DO THE DRUGS MOST
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND THE
EASIEST TO GET.
THAT AND ALSO THE DRUG'S MOST
ACCEPTABLE AND SO IF YOUR POLICY
IS TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF HARM
ASSOCIATED WITH DRUGS YOU WANT
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE REALLY LOUSY DRUGS
THAT HAVE MORE ACCESS TO THE
ONES LESS HARMFUL.
THE POINT ALEX IS TALKING ABOUT
GOES BACK TO ONE OF THE SORT OF
INTENDED OR SORT OF THE INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF NAFTA AND THIS
IS WHERE WE GET INTO THE MOTION
PUT FORWARD THERE IS NO SUCH
THING THE WAY WE IMPLEMENT THERE
IS NO SUCH THING AS DRUG POLICY
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR OTHER
POLICIES, ECONOMIC POLICY, TRADE
POLICY, HEALTHCARE POLICY
ESPECIALLY FOREIGN POLICY TRUMP.
WHENEVER DRUG POLICY IS A
CONCERN THERE IS NOTHING ELSE WE
FEEL LIKE DEALING WITH.
NAFTA IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THIS.
THE CLINTON ADMINISTRATION KNEW
THAT OPENING UP THE BORDER WOULD
BE A BOON TO THE DRUG CARTELS.
ONE OF HIS DRUG POLICY OFFICIALS
LATER CALLED IT A DEAL MADE IN
NORCO HAVE IN AND HE SAID TO HIS
DEA AND TO HIS DRUG CZAR UNTIL
NAFTA PASSES I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR A PEEP FROM YOU GUYS AND
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE A GOOD
THING IT'S JUST THE FACT HOW
DRUG POLICY IS TREATED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IT WAS A VERY TIGHT VOTE.
HE COULDN'T AFFORD TO LOSE A
COUPLE OF FOLKS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INCREASED DRUG TRAFFIC THAT
MIGHT COME FROM NAFTA.
I FOUND A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
STUDY THAT FOUND THAT THE
BIGGEST INCREASE IN OVERLAND
DRUG TRAFFICKING IN THE HISTORY
OF THE TIME THEY'VE BEEN
MENTIONING IT WAS THE YEAR 1994
NAFTA WENT INTO EFFECT
JANUARY 1ST, 1994.
IT WAS A PERFECT TIME TO BE A
MEXICAN DRUG CARTEL LEADER.
WE HAD JUST SMASHED THE
CARIBBEAN TRIET, THE CARIBBEAN
TO MIAMI TRADE ROUTE, AND THAT
PUSHED THE COKE TRADE OVER TO
MEXICO.
WE HAVE ALSO DECAPITATED A
COUPLE OF COLOMBIAN DRUG CARTELS
WHICH DECREASED THEIR POWER IN
RELATION TO THE MEXICAN CARTELS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAD ON
HARD AFTER THE DOMESTIC NEFF
INDUSTRY IN THE 80'S WHICH IS A
BUNCH OF BIKERS MAKING A FORM OF
SPEED THAT IS MUCH LESS POTENT
THAN THE ONE LEADER MADE BY THE
MEXICAN CAR CARTEL SO WE PUSHED
METH TO MEXICO, TO BACK.
SIMULTANEOUSLY FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES, CALIFORNIA STARTS
MAKING ITS BORDER MUCH MORE OF A
HASSLE TO GET OVER.
SO, THE DRUG CARTELS ARE KIND OF
JUST PUSHED BY ECONOMIC AND
OTHER POLITICAL FORCES EASTWARD
IN TEXAS, ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO,
WHICH SENDS THEM DIRECTLY OUT
INTO THE MIDWEST.
AND YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT LIKE THE
DRUG CARTELS ARE THINKING LIKE
HOW CAN WE CRACK THIS MARKET.
THAT IS WHAT BECAME AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
THAT'S WHERE THEY WENT AND THEN
METH BECOMES AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE
IN MISSOURI AND YOU HAVE WHAT'S
GOING ON NOW.
I INTERVIEWED A BUNCH OF IOWA
COPPS ABOUT ALL THE UNITED
STATES PASSED ABOUT SUDAFED AND
EPHEDRINE PRECURSORS AND THEY
SAID THEY WERE EXTREMELY HAPPY.
IT SHOT DOWN MOST OF THE LITTLE
TINY LABS PEOPLE WERE MAKING IN
THEIR TRAILERS.
THEY LIKED IT BECAUSE IT STOPPED
THIS TERRIBLE PROBLEM THEY HAVE
PEOPLE BLOGGING UP THEIR
TRAILERS AND BLOWING THEMSELVES
UP AND MAKING THESE TOXIC WASTE
SITES WHERE TODDLERS WERE EATING
THE PRECURSORS AND METH ITSELF.
IT WAS A DISASTER AND SO WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FINALLY
PASSED A STRICT PSEUDO VETERAN
WALL THE ONE COPPS SAID IT WAS
LIKE A LIGHT SWITCH, THE LABS
ALMOST DISAPPEARED AND I SAID SO
THE METH PROBLEM IS GOING DOWN?
HE WAS LIKE NO, NO, OUR METH HAS
ALWAYS COME FROM MEXICO OR AT
LEAST SINCE HE HAD BEEN DOING IT
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT THING.
THIS WAS JUST A COUPLE OF GUYS
COOKING UP SOME STUFF CAUSING
HUGE PROBLEMS, YOU KNOW, HEALTH
PROBLEMS FOR THEMSELVES BUT NOT
REALLY IMPACTING THE SUPPLY OF
THE DRUGS.
>> WE HEAR OFTEN NOW THAT KIDS
TAKE THE MEDICINE FROM THEIR
HOME AND GO TO PARTIES AND USE
WHATEVER IT IS.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> I THINK THAT THIS WILL BE
BOGUS.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY
CALL PHARM PARTIES WITH A "P-H"
AND IT'S GREAT TO WRITE ABOUT IF
YOU ARE A JOURNALIST.
THE THEORY IS THAT ALL THESE
KIDS NEED THEIR GARRISONS THAT
IS IN CABINET AND GO TO THE
PARTY AND THEY DUMP THEIR PILL
INTO A BIG JAR AND PEOPLE DIP
THEIR HANDS IN AND POP THEM.
I THINK FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
THAT IS CRAZY.
ONE IS THAT NO ONE IN ANY OF THE
REPORTING HAS ACTUALLY FOUND AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT HAPPENING.
YOU WILL GET TREATMENT PEOPLE
SAYING IT IS A PROBLEM OR YOU
MIGHT GET COPS SAYING IT'S A
PROBLEM, BUT NO REPORTER HAS
EVER FOUND AN ACTUAL CASE OF
ACTUALLY HAPPENING, WHICH OUGHT
TO BE A PREREQUISITE FOR
REPORTING IT IS NOT WHEN IT
COMES TO DRUG REPORTING.
JACK SHAFFER SLATE.COM HAS DONE
TERRIFIC WORK ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE AND YOU CAN ACTUALLY
GOOGLE HIS NAME AND PHARM
PARTIES AND FIND THAT NO ONE HAS
FOUND THIS.
BUT LOGICALLY, TOO.
THESE PARTIES WOULDN'T LAST LONG
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS.
ONE, MOST KIDS WOULD BRING
TICK-TOCKS.
YOU KNOW, LIKE WHY BRING YOUR
GOOD STUFF IF YOU'RE JUST GOING
TO DUMP IT INTO THE BOWL AND
THEN DID YOUR HANDS IN THERE AND
TAKE SOMETHING ELSE?
OR YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BRING.
PEOPLE WOULD BE A DAUNTING.
THIS IS NOT THE KIND OF THING
THAT YOU COULD CONCEAL FROM
REPORTERS WHO WOULD LOVE TO
WRITE THE STORY OF THIS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING.
NOW, I DO WRITE ABOUT THE RISE
OF TEEN DRUG USE SINCE 2001 IN
THIS BOOK AND I HAVE KIND OF AN
AWFUL HERE I CAN'T PROVE IT, BUT
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO ME AND
SINCE THIS IS THE CLOSEST TO
TODAY IT IS ONE OF THE HARDER
TRENDS TO EXAMINE, WHICH IS
IRONIC, BUT AROUND 2000, 2001
JOOST OR TO SEE MARIJUANA USE
DECLINE AND IT'S SOMETHING LIKE
30% SINCE 2000.
TEAM MARIJUANA USE COMING DOWN.
THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE TEAM
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE COMING
UP BY ABOUT 10%.
SO, WHAT HAPPENED?
BETWEEN 1990 AND NOW FOR 2,000
TO CAUSE THAT?
A COUPLE TRENDS WORKING
TOGETHER.
ONE OF THEM IS OVER SCHEDULING I
THINK.
STARTING IN THE 80'S AND THEN
ACCELERATING THROUGH THE 90'S,
KIDS HAVE MUCH LESS FREE TIME.
FREE TIME IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
NEED IF -- GENERALLY IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE SMOKING MARIJUANA.
IT'S THE KIND OF DRUG WHERE FIVE
KIDS GET TOGETHER, GO OUT BEHIND
A SHED, THE ALLEY, THE WOODS.
ONE PERSON HAS IT COME TO PASS
IT AROUND TO EACH OTHER AND THEN
-- SO IF THAT ONE KID WHO HAS IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE FREE TIME
ANYMORE ALL FIVE OF THOSE KIDS
THAT DAY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
DOING ANYTHING.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, I FEEL
THERE HAS BEEN THE ROLE OF THE
INTERNET.
WHEN YOU HAVE DID YOU GAMES,
SOCIAL AND WORKING, TWITTER,
FACEBOOK, ET CETERA, ET CETERA,
AND KIDS ARE COMING HOME FROM
SCHOOL AND INSTEAD OF HANGING
OUT WITH EACH OTHER THEY ARE
HANGING OUT WITH EACH OTHER BUT
ONLINE, YOU KNOW, THROUGH A
COMPUTER.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M SURE THERE IS A FACEBOOK AT
LIKE JOHNNY CINGULAR JOINT.
BUT THAT ISN'T GOING TO SHOW UP
ON THE SURVEY DATA.
LAUGHTER COMES A KID SITTING AT
HOME LIKE THAT MIGHT STILL HAVE
THIS APPETITE FOR STIMULATION AS
THE MASSACHUSETTS BOARD PUT IT.
AND THEY WILL USE THE F-ING MOST
BRAUDY IN HAND AND I WOULD BE
THE MEDICINE CAP NEARBY.
IT MAKES SENSE TO ME, I CAN'T
USE THAT COMES A THAT IS MY TAKE
ON THAT PART.
ANYBODY?
>> I WAS JUST WONDERING WHAT IS
THE PRESIDENT AND THE GOVERNMENT
AND WHAT IS BEING DRAWN TO END
THE WAR ON DRUGS?
>> WE RHETORICALLY ENDED WHEN
OBAMA TOOK OVER THE DRUG CZAR
SAID THAT HE WAS NO LONGER GOING
TO USE THE PHRASE WAR ON DRUGS.
WHICH IS NICE BUT PROBABLY
LITTLE SOLACE TO A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE BUYING OR IN PRISON AS A
RESULT THE MOST IMMEDIATE
DIRECTION THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
CAN GO IS PROBABLY IN ITS
FUNDING, AND ITS FUNDING
DECISIONS.
YOU HAVE IT BROKEN DOWN BY
ENFORCEMENT AND TREATMENT OR
SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
BUSH WAS VERY MUCH AND SO WAS
CLINTON, VERY HEAVY INTO
SPENDING MONEY ON ENFORCEMENT,
MONEY ON THE SUPPLY SIDE.
THAT IS COMPLETELY WASTEFUL.
THERE IS A RAND CORPORATION
STUDY FROM -- THAT THE CLINTON
COMMISSIONED THE SHOWED IT WAS
SOMETHING LIKE 172 TIMES MORE
WASTEFUL TO SPEND MONEY ON THE
SUPPLY SIDE BECAUSE IT IS SO
HARD.
YOU KNOW, WRAPPING UP SOME COCA
GROWER'S PLANT DOES NOTHING FOR
ADDICTION RATES IN THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
WAYS THAT COULD BE ADAPTED.
YOU GET ONE ADDICT TO STOP BEING
AN ADDICT AND YOU HAVE REDUCED
DRUG USE BY, YOU KNOW, AND
NON-TRIVIAL AMOUNT BECAUSE IT IS
THE ADDICTS WHO WERE DOING SUCH
A PERCENTAGE OF THE DRUGS.
NOW, THE FIRST STEP FOR OBAMA
WOULD BE TO HONESTLY BUDGET
THAT, AND HE RAN ON TRANSPARENCY
AND HONEST ACCOUNTING, SO THAT
IS HOPEFULLY SOMETHING THAT HE
WILL DO.
RIGHT NOW, HE DOESN'T BECAUSE
I'M NOT GOING TO BRING HIM UP
FOR IT YET, BUT HE ADOPTED THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION POLICY OF
NOT COUNTING PRISON COSTS AS
PART OF ENFORCEMENT.
WHICH WOULD BE LIKE, YOU KNOW,
NOT COUNTING THE TREATMENT
CENTER COSTS IN THE TREATMENT
CENTER SITE.
SO IS HIS GOAL IS TO GET TO
SOMETHING BALANCED LIKE A 5050
SPENDING RATIO, AND HE DOES IT
HONESTLY, AND COUNTS PRISON
COSTS, THEN HE WOULD HAVE TO
SPEND A LOT MORE MONEY ON DRUG
COURT AND TREATMENT AND OTHER
WAYS TO APPROACH.
SO THAT'S PROBABLY THE BEST
DIRECTION HE CAN GO.
THERE IS SOME GOOD NEWS I
REPORTED THE OTHER DAY.
A BILL THAT JUST CAME OUT OF THE
HOUSE, BASICALLY IT ELIMINATES
THIS CAMPAIGN, THIS ANTI-DRUG
MEDIA CAMPAIGN THAT'S BEEN
RUNNING FOR DECADES NOW.
THERE HAS BEEN A BUNCH OF
STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN THAT IT
ISN'T EFFECTIVE AND THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME STUDIES THAT ACTUALLY
INCLINED SOME KIDS TO ACTUALLY
TRY DRUGS AFTER THEY SEE THE AD
AND THAT'S WHAT THE COMMITTEE
REPORT WROTE WHEN THEY WERE
CUTTING IT LIKE WHY ARE WE
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
THIS CAMPAIGN THAT CAN'T PROVE
ITS EFFECTIVENESS?
I ASKED THE DRUG CZAR FOR
COMMENT AND THE COMMENT WAS
ACCURATE.
THEY SAID THIS IS ONE OF THE
MOST WELL-KNOWN, MOST WELL KNOWN
AD CAMPAIGN BRANDS IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S ONE OF THE BEST KNOWN
BRANDS IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
I DO NOT ARGUE WITH THAT.
BUT IF THAT IS THE BEST THAT CAN
BE SAID THAT IT'S VERY
WELL-KNOWN, THEN I DON'T SEE THE
POINT OF IT.
THE SECOND POINT IS THE GAME
ISN'T OVER.
WE HAVE FAITH IN THE SENATE THEY
WILL RESTORE THIS MONEY.
SO IT IS A PUSH AND PULL ALL THE
WAY THROUGH.
>> THE LAST QUESTION I ASKED AS
EVERY AUTHOR COMES THROUGH, I'VE
DONE THIS A COUPLE OF YEARS, BUT
MY FAVORITE BOOK YOU HAVE READ
WROTE THE LAST YEAR, IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU JUST READ HALF OF
IT, A QUARTER OF IT, IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW.
>> SOME PEOPLE MIGHT MAKE FUN OF
ME FOR THIS, BUT I READ TOWARD
THE END OF WRITING THIS I READ
THE BOUGHT ME A DESIRE AND I
KNOW SOME PEOPLE PETE BATT BOOK
-- PEOPLE HATE THAT BOOK, BUT
THE CHAPTER HE WROTE ON CANVAS,
MICHAEL POLLAN BOOK, WAS
EXCELLENT.
HE DESCRIBES -- FROM A
JOURNALISTIC APPROACH, HE CALLS
ALL KIND OF RESEARCHERS BUREAU
SCIENTISTS, ETC., AND SAYS WHY
DO PEOPLE GET HIGH?
AND HE CALLS PHILOSOPHERS, TOO,
AND HE COMES UP WITH WHAT I
THINK IS THE BEST EXPLANATION
ANYBODY SO FAR HAS.
IT'S VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
YOU CAN SEE IT, YOU CAN SEE THE
WAY IT UNFOLDS AND SO I ALMOST
MYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYMYM,
BIOLOGISTS AND ASKED THEM THAT.
HE DID A GREAT JOB WITH THAT.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
[APPLAUSE]
..